right well I would let me answer that
call I mean let me avoid that question
perhaps right because I think that what
has become increasingly clear at the end
of the 20th century is how much 20th
century art is trying to teach us about
objects and about object culture which
is to say about how objects make meaning
objects make meaning for us and I think
right now certainly within the
contemporary art world there's so much
installation work right and i'm thinking
of Tara Donovan's incredible styrofoam
cups which end up looking like clouds
because glued together a lot of
refabricate Anor Sarah's A's production
of these object ecologies so it's you
know toothpicks q-tips some scraps of
this and then the other thing and they
they end up being this sort of cosmos
and artists like that I think and not in
just those artists i think really mean
to be alerting our attention to other
ways that objects might be configured or
as i like to put or have put it in one
essay or another the possibility that
the material world might want to be
organized other than the way we've
organized it right so that the that they
the desire the denim of your jeans or
the cotton of your t-shirt and the
object of its desire might be to be a
different object right your t-shirt
might actually want to be part of a fly
yeah something along those lines and i
think it's a it's been a very
contemporary artists been very powerful
conduit to those sorts of ideas and
those sorts of ideas philosophically are
very much part of say vitalism on making
of only barracks on and then Barisan as
as we thought bye-bye de leurs
but it's I think it's only in the
presence of such art that you really
experience some of these alternatives or
is that where I'm where I'm calling
something like the the desire the
inanimate object world's desire to be
reconfigured to have a different shape
right and right now around around the
city around your city if you look at
roscoes work in the moma with the with
something like the the yogurt tops on
four different walls or as Fisher at the
new museum those huge aluminum
sculptures these are all this is all
work that is very powerful I think
dramatizing that the presence of objects
and the importance of objects as opposed
to say images and I think that you know
if something happened in the 20th
century it's that image culture ended up
trumping object culture and we have
great theories of image culture to
divorce Society of the spectacle Beaudry
ours orders of simulacra and and we do I
think also have powerful theories of the
object but I think that it's really
image culture and that that got the most
attention and that towards the end of
the last century there's also there's
another artist a Chicago artist marie
craine Bergman who has for years been
doing vast monochrome arm canvases made
up of very very small earth helix of
paint and now 1 of the practices that
she's taken up is to put paint acrylic
paint on the floor and then to pick it
up and hang the paint after its dried
and I mean the paint so she will do
grids for instance and hanging them up
and in the grid will sag a bit and and
one of the obvious effects of that work
is to make one recognize that your paint
is never still the paint is always
moving you know if
15th century painting that painted still
moving it might be moving very slowly
but it's moving and it's and it's also
you know to my mind a fascinating way
for painting to be attending to a
different material ground not as
Greenberg and others would say about
flatness about about the shape of the
canvas but rather to the paint itself
right so now it's just the the paint
unsupported as it were supported just by
a nail that becomes the art object but
there's another moment where you know
you really do experience with those
works the the vitality of paint even if
it's a drooping